I bought every wine term today the
underpriced attention is Facebook reels
in 1998 Wine Library had 150 000 people
on its email newsletter and had a 91.3
open rates Google AdWords when they came
out I bought every wine term they were
five cents floor for about eight months
or so before 10 cents became the floor
and literally I owned every word from
wine itself to Silver Oak to Chateau
lefe and I was able to build a very
large business for my dad with very
little Capital because I was able to
understand where the underpriced
attention was and I was able to
understand how to fill that underpriced
attention with the creative whether that
was the copywriting back then